und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka
guten abend auf haiti hat es wieder ein
schweres erdbeben gegeben im moment ist
in den nachrichtenagenturen von mehreren
hundert toten die rede doch zu so einem
frühen zeitpunkt lassen sich die
tatsächlichen ausmaße noch überhaupt
nicht absehen das beben hatte eine
stärke von 7,2 das ist sogar noch etwas
stärker als das verheerende erdbeben von
2010 bei dem hunderttausende menschen
ums leben kam allerdings lag das
epizentrum damals praktisch direkt in
der dicht besiedelten hauptstadt
protokolls diesmal war es im südwesten
der karibikinsel was ist bisher an
informationen und bildern gibt trägt
claudia babes zusammen
gerettet menschen werden aus den
trümmern geborgen die von ihren häusern
übrig sind das erdbeben hat den
karibikstaat zahlreiche gebäude zerstört
und menschen unter dem schutt begraben
die krankenhäuser sind völlig überlastet
verletzte werden zum teil draußen
provisorisch versorgt essen und
notunterkünfte fehlen in der nähe des
epizentrums im südwesten sind laut
zivilschutzbehörden orte völlig zerstört
wir sind bei der bewertung wir hören es
gebe starke zerstörung tote in ihren
häusern krankenhäuser und straßen
zerstört ich werde sehen wie wir hilfe
organisieren können
rettungsteams in die betroffenen gebiete
zu schicken ist schwierig wegen der
schlechten und zerstörten infrastruktur
und kriminellen gangs die regionen
kontrollieren wir bitten um viel
solidarität und zwar strukturierte
solidarität wir setzen eine task force
ein um hilfe zu organisieren so dass es
nicht wieder so wird wie beim erdbeben
von 2010
wegen unterbrochener internet und
telefonverbindungen kommen die berichte
aus den besonders betroffenen regionen
nur schleppend so ist das ausmaß noch
unklar in den nächsten tagen wird in
haiti außerdem ein tropensturm erwartet
der die aufräum- und rettungsarbeiten
zusätzlich behindern kann
dann blicken wir nach afghanistan die
bundeswehr bereitet sich darauf vor
deutsche staatsbürger und auch
afghanische kräfte außer landes zu
bringen das muss jetzt schnell gehen der
vormarsch der taliban verläuft rasant
täglich werden neue eroberungen
verkündet nach übereinstimmenden
meldungen haben die taliban jetzt auch
masar-i-scharif eingenommen die
großstadt im norden in der die
bundeswehr bis vor wenigen wochen noch
ihr hauptquartier in afghanistan hatte
und die taliban rücken auch kabul immer
näher katrin eigendorf beginnt ihren
bericht in gasen von dort sind es nur
noch 140 kilometer bis kabul sie
scheinen sich sicher zu fühlen
taliban-kämpfer am straßenrand in ghazni
unser zdf kamera man darf in der
provinzmetropole filmen in der die
islamisten vor zwei tagen erst die macht
übernommen haben mit amerikanischen
humvee die die armee zurückgelassen hat
fahren sie durch die stadt in einem
sportstadion halten sie nach eigenen
angaben 300 soldaten gefangen alle
hätten sich widerstandslos ergeben
behaupten die kämpfer und kündigen an
ganz afghanistan und alle muslime werden
unter die kontrolle der taliban kommen
die verwaltung wird ihre arbeit
aufnehmen und das system des islamischen
emirats wird im ganzen land kommen so
gott will
in kabul es gut gesicherten botschafts
und regierungsviertel laufen die
vorbereitungen für den ernstfall immer
mehr länder auch deutschland ziehen
botschaftspersonal ab die befürchtung
dass auch die hauptstadt bald von den
taliban eingenommen werden könnte wächst
am hamid karzai flughafen drängt
afghanistans mittelschicht zu den
fliegern nur raus aus dem land in
sicherheit
präsident ashraf ghani wendet sich heute
mit einer botschaft an sein volk
prosinecki in der aktuellen situation
ist die re integration unserer
sicherheits und verteidigungsrechte
unsere priorität
tag für tag wird deutlich afghanistans
armee 20 jahre ausgebildet und
unterstützt von westlichen militärs
scheitert auf sich alleine gestellt
obwohl das militär personell und
technisch den taliban überlegen ist wie
konnte das passieren
eine armee kann so ausgerüstet sein die
besten waffen haben aber wenn sie nicht
die moral haben zu kämpfen kann man
nicht viel machen
verantwortlich für das scheitern sei der
präsident diese überzeugung setzt sich
in afghanistan immer mehr durch
forderungen nach seinem rücktritt werden
drängender die afghanische regierung hat
nicht nur moralisch ihre glaubwürdigkeit
verloren sie hatten nicht einmal einen
charismatischen führer sie haben diesen
krieg entsetzlich schlecht gemanagt und
die resultate sehen wir jetzt
ein rücktritt des afghanischen
präsidenten es scheint nur eine frage
der zeit dass ashraf ghani dem druck
nachgibt
und wie in deutschland auf die
entwicklung in afghanistan reagiert wird
damit beginnen jetzt die nachrichten vom
bundes aus
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat in einer
krisensitzung telefonisch mit einem teil
des kabinetts über das vorgehen beraten
mit hilfe der bundeswehr sollen
schnellstmöglich mitarbeiter der
deutschen botschaft ortskräfte und
beschäftigte deutscher organisationen
aus afghanistan ausgeflogen werden
können die vorbereitungen dafür laufen
grünen kanzlerkandidat in bernburg
forderte im deutschlandfunk alle 27 eu
länder müssten sich gemeinsam auf eine
aufnahme von flüchtlingen aus
afghanistan vorbereiten in deutschland
ist die korona impfquote leicht
gestiegen auf glatt 57 knapp
47,4 millionen menschen sind nun
vollständig geimpft das robert koch
institut registrierte
5644 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
2438 mehr als vor einer woche elf
menschen starben an oder mit dem virus
die sieben tage inzidenz steigt weiter
auf jetzt
32,7 auch an diesem wochenende haben in
frankreich zehntausende gegen die korona
politik der regierung protestiert
ihre kritik richtet sich dabei vor allem
gegen die impfpflicht im
gesundheitswesen und den gesundheitspass
diesen brauchen die menschen in
frankreich an allen öffentlichen orten
um nachzuweisen dass sie geimpft genesen
oder getestet sind
noch rund sechs wochen bis zur
bundestagswahl und damit beginnt jetzt
die sogenannte heiße wahlkampfphase in
der die politischen parteien gerne noch
mal in aller form zum wahlkampfauftakt
blasen was natürlich eine etwas
irreführende formulierung ist denn
wahlkampf haben wir ja schon seit wochen
beziehungsweise gar monaten aber jetzt
beginnt der schlussspurt plakate hängen
schon und in knapp zwei wochen geht es
dann auch los mit wahlkampf spots im
fernsehen
die spd hat ihren offiziellen
startschuss für die letzte strecke auf
dem heutigen samstag gelegt nach bochum
rotes traditions- regieren und ihr
spitzenkandidat konnte dort mit weit
mehr rückenwind auftreten als er sich
das bei seiner kür vor einem jahr
ausmalen konnte andreas huppert und
lassen sagt berichten
er ist plötzlich angesagt und wie in der
partei und auch beim wahl folgt er den
die eigene partei nicht als vorsitzenden
wollte führt momentan klar bei der frage
wen wollen sie lieber als kanzler doch
olaf scholz kann oder will den braten
selber noch nicht so richtig traum
nicht zu laut aber
ausdrücklich sage ich viele haben das
gefühl da gibt es eine partei die die
zukunft anpackt und der aufbruch der für
unser land nötig ist das ist was die
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
anpacken wollen das spüren wir den
umfragen liebe freundinnen und freunde
leise ist das gebot der stunde die sonst
eher streitsüchtige spd schafft es
eitelkeiten und animositäten beiseite zu
lassen genüsslich verweist der
generalsekretär darauf dass die
heckenschützen gerade er bei der
konkurrenz unterwegs sind
wir haben als spd kein robert habeck der
sich in talkshows setzen und gegen die
eigenen kanzlerkandidaten poltert wir
haben kein markus söder der permanent
armin laschet wieder heraus fordert der
stichelt der deutlich macht das ist
nicht mein kanzlerkandidat sondern wir
haben olaf scholz vorne stehen wir haben
starkes team dahinter die spd die sich
immer selbstbewusst als programmpartei
verstand nun verkauft hat die mutiert in
diesem wahlkampf zum kanzlerkandidaten
wahlverein sie können auch damit leben
dass er eine olaf scholz wahl ist als
eine spd war
ja ich glaube dass viele wissen ich muss
spd wählen und ich will es die wellen
weil olaf scholz dann auch kanzler wird
und olaf scholz ist ein sozialdemokrat
das weiß ich aus jahren von
zusammenarbeit insofern ist das keine
trennung der eine oder die andere
scholz zieht seine derzeitige stärke
auch aus der schwäche der politischen
konkurrenz der spd kanzlerkandidat im
angriffsmodus gegen den noch
koalitionspartner eine weitere von cdu
csu geführte bundesregierung kostet
deutschland wohlstand arbeitsplätze und
zukunft das darf nicht sein in seiner
gut 40 minütigen rede fordert scholz
immer wieder respekt und den
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft dafür
brauche es einen mindestlohn von 12 euro
sozial gerechten klimaschutz und
bezahlbares wohnen und das gehört doch
dazu wenn man ein gutes leben führen
will dass man sich die eigene wohnung
leisten kann das auch eine normale
arbeitnehmern ein normaler arbeitnehmer
doch noch mal die perspektive hat sich
vielleicht ein kleines häuschen ab zu
sparen das muss in diesem land möglich
sein und dafür müssen wir kämpfen bei
den rund 1300 genossinnen und genossen
heute hier in bochum kommt das gut an
wer ein gutes programm wir haben guten
kandidaten läuft die bevölkerung hat
inzwischen begriffen dass hier ein
sachlicher mensch am arbeit und kein
fantast irgendwelche dinge verspricht
von ihm versprechen sich die mitglieder
vor allem eins nichts weniger als die
kanzlerschaft für die spd
jetzt noch mal weitere meldungen bundes
oder die türkei leidet weiter unter
wetterextremen
im süden der türkei konnten die meisten
brände mittlerweile gelöscht werden
allerdings kamen heute beim absturz
eines russischen löschflugzeuge es dort
alle acht insassen ums leben zugleich
ist der norden der türkei von
verheerenden überschwemmungen schwer
getroffen die zahl der todesopfer ist
auf mindestens 55 gestiegen einige
bewohner warfen den behörden vor nicht
rechtzeitig vor den gefahren durch
heftige regenfälle gewarnt zu haben eine
vielzahl von bränden macht weiterhin dem
süden italiens zu schaffen in kalabrien
sind die feuerwehren in hunderten
einsätzen bislang verloren vier menschen
ihr leben in den waldbränden italiens
extreme hitze im raum palermo auf
sizilien und auf sardinien sowie
anhaltende trockenheit lassen glutnester
immer wieder in flammen aufgehen
gleich die wetteraussichten für
deutschland hier zunächst die
gewinnzahlen vom lotto sie lauten ohne
gewähr 2 17 19 29 39 48 superzahl 1
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 das
sommerwetter hierzulande bleibt
wechselhaft unwetter sind möglich morgen
gibt es im norden dichte wolken und
etwas regen sonst viel sonne ab dem
nachmittag im süden einige teils
kräftige gewitter lokal mit starkregen
hagel und sturmböen höchstwerte 20 bis
32 grad die neue woche wird eher
unbeständig mit einer mischung aus sonne
wolken regen und gewittern zudem wird es
sehr windig und deutlich kühler
das war es von uns am samstagabend
gleich gehts mit dem aktuellen
sportstudio weiter und um 0.25 gibt's
nochmal nachrichten ja auch wieder
selbst morgen und sonntag solltest du
nicht mehr werden
[Musik]